[Music]
this is the end very funny movie
I got a screening copy and I'm watching
it I thought this is gonna kill with
audiences they're gonna really love it
are you ever tempted when I moot when a
comedy of yours is coming out to go and
see it with a crowd and sort of watch
them react especially when it's one this
funny yeah I just like to see what
people laugh at like that isn't really
interesting for me to check out and once
I was in a movie theater with my buddy
and and we were sitting there in a
trailer it was a big summer movie it was
like some action movie and they wished
they showed a trailer for one of the
movies that I was in and I was trying to
make my buddy laugh and we were in the
theater and after the trailer ended I
just yell out cuz like it's a dark
theater no one knows I'm there I don't
know it's you yeah and just sighs go I'm
seeing that right and my buddy's kind of
laughing kind of like you're an idiot
and then the guy in front of me who has
no idea it's me just goes yeah maybe on
an airplane
[Laughter]
it's like one of the most humbling moves
like I don't know your uh your end is
about you before your your hip hop in
you're a pretty big hip hop I'm like
that's a big part of my life I know that
sounds crazy but I grew up like I
worship hip hop I it's like almost all I
listen to you and then I think was it 21
Jump Street where you got to work with
Ice Cube so when we were writing the
first 21 Jump Street we the first thing
we wrote down was the guy who wrote F
the police is gonna play the police
captain nice cute
the first idea we had and I called him
and he did it and it was like a dream
come true for me I got to spend all this
time with him asked him about NWA and
all this stuff and what was cool was
when Channing and I were on that trip
Ice Cube was on part of it so we were on
a plane with Ice Cube and so you forget
like you're traveling you've been
working on that you forget that like Ice
Cube is there with you you know like it
he's not just he's not a normal person
York you think like he's the actor in
the movie with you you forget that he's
that Ice Cube and he was like my hero
growing up you know I'm from LA
he's like the West Coast champion like I
like except for iced tea I thank you so
so we're their enchanting eyes just a
great at night we're on a plane and
we're like kind of having this
conversation cuz Channing loves hit pop
too we're like who's the best rapper of
all time like whatever we're talking a
Tupac biggie whatever and I'm like just
like I would turn to a friend who was in
the plane with us and I go hey cube cuz
we call him Kizer shorten it up yeah
that's what he told me to call him I
didn't take that Liberty uh so I turn
around like you but who's the best
rapper of all time and he goes me mother
[Laughter]
you're talking - yeah I thought that was
great let's talk about this is the end
of course you're in this movie with all
your pals you all get to play versions
of yourself yeah just do she awful
versions of ourselves like it's
basically making fun of how actors are
ridiculous and don't know how to do
anything in life and if there wasn't
apocalypse they just complain the whole
time it's all you guys it's you James
Franco's I broke it you guys are all in
a house together and it's the end of the
world and you don't have the best skills
for dealing with it nobody would but you
guys know cuz the joke is that like
actors have like assistants and stuff
and like don't even know how to like get
their own coffee and stuff and we make
fun of each other so badly in this movie
like everyone just gets attacked our bad
movies get made fun of constantly it's
super funny and it's really fun to watch
and what's interesting is James Franco
he gets to to promote the movie painted
a mural have you seen the mural he
painted for the movie he sent it to me
he painted this mural that depicts all
of you anybody would check you out
what's going on
no I put what's that although I think
James sees me as a grave robber from the
1,400 who's now a ghost it's like he's
like do you like the mirror like it's
awesome yeah what are you gonna say yeah
yeah maybe he's blind I don't know you
know
no he's such a talented artist in like I
was all for and I thought it was cool
but when I see it I just and like I
should get a tan or something like that